we are
back with my nearest and dearest Lucy
Lou
all right so you're here to talk about
Shazam which you are so money I want to
talk to you about like
[Music]
an amazing place to like channel that
hotness and that energy and that
capability I mean huh so
I'll show it and then we'll talk about
it
[Music]
thank you
That's The Power of Chaos
just Whispering it's so hot why am I
turned on by that because it's sexy
actually well they're goddesses so they
have powers that most people don't okay
Dame Helen Mirren plays your sister and
I heard like
she she like made an impression at the
first part of like her coming on the set
what's that story well she shows up on
time and she's her thing is
Beyond time and don't be
[Applause]
and then she's like that's all
that's all you have to do and not
everyone can do that obviously but
that's her motto and it works and you
know what she does it and she's she's
Perfection I love that okay well as I
was trying to find our nudes I did find
these old pictures that's believe it or
not that's you me and Cameron
how cute I feel like really in Vegas
no that's not our Vegas trip yeah I mean
that is the essence of like I mean come
on yeah yes
just having it up
Hamming it up just can we be like that
until we pass on to whatever's out there
after that that's the only choice we
have that's the only thing that's the
only choice it's fun forever Joy our
kids Our Lives ourselves you know I mean
if anything this whole situation with
the pandemic has taught us or me is like
we just have to cherish every moment
we just do and I do I cherish every
moment with you
[Applause]
thank you okay Shazam Fury of the Gods
is in theaters and I'm Max now and um
yeah we'll be right back I love you
[Music]